تبدو قضيه الوثائق السريه التي احتفظ بها
الرئيس الحالي جو فايدن والرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب مؤشرا على مشكله حقيقيه
تواجهها اجهزه الدوله الامريكيه مع
الرؤساء الامريكيين
السيناتور الديمقراطيه
كشفها كيف يتم التعامل مع الوثائق المصنفه
السريه
لكن المساله مختلفه مع الرئيس الامريكي من
الممكن ان نرى الرئيس سبايدر وهو يغادر
وبيده اوراق ويذهب الى مقر الاقامه في
المبنى الرئيسي من البيت الابيض او الى
الطائره لا احد يتابع مع الرئيس الامريكي
ما حصل للاوراق المصنفه سريه
ومرقمه ولا احد يسال عنها او يطلب
استعادتها من الرئيس عندما يغادر او عندما
ينتهي من استعمالها هذه واحده من المشاكل
لكن ما حصل مع بيضه ومن قبله ترامب يتراوح
بين الاهمال والاصرار على عدم احترام
الاجراءات الامنيه وحمايه الوثائق السريه
فبعض الوثائق موجود بحوزه بايضا منذ كان
عضو مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي وقبل ان يصبح
نائبا للرئيس العام 2009
نظام المكتبات العامه وعندما يعطى الرئيس
وثيقه وهي عاده تاتي من السي اي اي او
وزاره الدفاع يجب ان تكون مسجله ومرقمه
الحل الاخر المطروح هو تحويل
كسريه الى النظام الالكتروني وبالتالي
يقفل الدخول اليها بمجرد انتهاء الرئيس من
استعمالها وهذا ما حصل في الايجاز الامني
للرئيس في المكتب البيضاء